avec la crise épidémique l' agence
régionale de santé a demandé aux
hôpitaux de reporter les interventions
non urgentes et limiter les activités de
soins pour pouvoir se concentrer sur les
passions dicko vide
la pandémie est en recul les activités
hospitalières reviennent petit à petit à
la normale c'est ce que nous allons
aborder avec eric luz directeur de
l'hôpital privé de versailles bonjour
bonjour madame alors tout d'abord
comment ça s'est passé pour vous cette
période si particulière au sein de votre
établissement
il avait dit à juste titre que nous
avons activé nos parents dans blanc le 7
mars le dernier et dans la foulée c'est
à dire dès le 13 mars des programmes et
toutes nos interventions chirurgicales
non urgentes d'avenir
tous les patients ne nécessiteront pas
le passé le opératoire dans le cadre
d'un mot bien le service des urgences
les patients effectivement il n'y a pas
de risque de perte de chance de voir
leurs interventions chirurgicales
reporter ou encore les patients atteints
d'un cancer et donc nous avons
transformé un intégralité de l'hôpital
de versailles dans 6 2 pour accueillir
j'ai un petit tour la vague que nous
avons effectivement tous vécu en
capacité d'accueillir des patients
atteints du co lead ce que nous avons
créé puisque nous avons transformé notre
salle de réveil en réanimation la
capacité dix patients où tout cela va
nous sept patients en simultané ou 5000
service de réanimation où bizouard est
également une hospitalisation de
médecine comme byd qui effectivement
iplayer opérationnel pendant plus d'un
mois avec bien évidemment à sa vie
d'urgence qui a lui aussi ce dernier
puisqu'il est venu finalement comique de
service et en parallèle un point
pour les passes effectivement sinon
coville est effectivement pour les
patients comme le niqab
dimanche aussi d'aller prendre en charge
dans les meilleures conditions
quelle est la session aujourd'hui
comment préparez-vous la réintroduction
des patients non coved alors victime
[Musique]
comme on tient des médias le relais
depuis plusieurs semaines des milieux
s'est considérablement contractée au
genou parle le patient coville au sein
d'établissements qui nous sommes
restructurés vous pouvoir modestement
programmer les patients effectivement
que nous avions des coupables et depuis
mi mars dernier avait effectivement une
nécessité d'être très vigilants le sur
les parcours de prise en charge avec
deux parcours qui sont identifiés à la
fois par les patients ils sont les
banquiers de lego kill dem écoulé s'est
soldé plus des prix en charge
chirurgicale mans c'est notre
établissement les autres patients cog
hill et non que nous avons aujourd'hui
au sein des blocs opératoires sadisme et
il est en charge des patients mais aussi
comme id
ils comptent effectivement sur nos
services d'hospitalisation avec un
questionnaire à la fois l'entrée pour
les patients ou invités ou s'assurer ou
là des prélèvements peuvent être
prescrits par les médecins qui ne sont
pas reporter effectivement du coc vide
mais aussi un questionnaire à l'ensemble
des chirurgiens vont pouvoir motiver
leurs indications chirurgicales
autrement dit sur une analyse de
mikeline mission consiste à pile ou qui
remet les intérêts de ben charge le
patient maintenant au bloc opératoire
il faut que dans quelques semaines abete
animations en ville en charge chez nous
aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça rassure les patients ça
parce qu'on observe des fois des
personnes dont la maladie peuvent
s'aggraver parce qu'ils n'osent plus
aller à l'hôpital ou chez un médecin
tout simplement côtés de plusieurs
semaines même le clip début d'épidémie
que des patients doit continuer
activement à venir au sein de nos
services des urgences il exprime
bâtiment ou une nécessité de venir tous
les médecins aussi développer la
téléconsultation qui permet semblé
accepter des petits malins ou d'un
généraliste inciter les patients à
consulter
physiquement ou à distance la médecin
les patients dont les opérations peut
être déprogrammée puis reprogrammé est
ce que le lien était maintenue comment
ça pas été trop difficile de leur
expliquer ça les médias d'information il
à libération certains patients l'ont
finalement rester chez eux plutôt que de
venir effectivement cependant charge sur
les interventions non urgentes
en pleine crise ça libère des petits
paquets missiles le différend la boucle
et tu es le lia toujours des petits
moments de nul entre le praticien qui le
patient lors d'art qui voulait aborder
avec vous la thématique de
l'accouchement
on a vu émerger pas mal de témoignages
de jeunes mamans pour qui ça a été
difficile de se retrouver seul comment
on fait pour les accompagner ces femmes
là dans une période comme celle ci il a
été difficile pour nous d'un ver di
respectivement toutes les visites très
rapidement au début de la crise un
salutaire que les papas ou assister à
l'accouchement et donc ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui plaît
des patientes et depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant les papas la
possibilité également de rendre visite à
leur famille et à l'enfant cela
effectivement tous les jours avec des
contraintes d'hygiène
il est papa l'hôpital complètement sera
organisée aujourd'hui où on est on est
ce qu'on va vers une voie où on revient
un peu à la normale
alors j'ai envie de vous dire là on est
sur une nouvelle passe finalement de
notre plan blanc tu ne passes mais deux
c'est à dire que le niveau 2 du plan
blanc nécessite de déprogrammer toutes
les interventions de sonder
programmables donc globalement tous les
établissements des dépenses reste à
dimension de leur plan blanc seule
région qui concerne aujourd'hui ça
changera probablement sur la deuxième
des compliments qui aura lieu le 22 juin
prochain
mais au moment où je vous parle nous
avons effectivement déjà revu nos
pratiques puisque nous allons désormais
effectivement élevé
tous les patients qui doivent être pris
en charge chez nous donc on va organiser
une besner à partir de début de la
semaine prochaine au moins 48 heures
avant leur admission au pouvoir
confirmer effectivement qui ne sont pas
collectivement du covili de ce qui nous
permettrait d'être plus souple sur
effectivement que la prise en charge
dans cet hôpital mutation et au bloc
opératoire mais néanmoins on conserve un
tri à l'entrée tous les visiteurs les
accompagnants avec un port du mans ce
système à timimoun ainsi que les
visiteurs et les patients à se munir
d'un masque des signes parlent aux mets
systématiquement un masque chirurgical
lavage des mains est naturellement est
quasiment systématique et puis bien
évidemment des visites sont aujourd'hui
encore extrêmement régulé et les
interventions blocs opératoires reste
qu'elle conditionnait sur des teams en
cette appréciation le chirurgien de
prendre en charge le patient maintenant
double demain avec mes clips là j'avais
plus évoqués précédemment
je vais vous dire me semble pas encore
sûr un fonctionnement normal mais les
jours et les semaines était petit mois
qui s'annonce nous laisse penser pour
l'ensemble merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien
berkshire où je le rappelle vous êtes
directeur de l'hôpital privé de
versailles